a fast-food chain in Brazil is selling
burgers wrapped in edible paper and hey
look it's mr. teabag Vsauce Kevin here
this is mine researchers from Spain have
developed this eco-friendly brick by
using waste from paper mills and mixing
it with clay they pressurize and extrude
it like a sausage to create these paper
building blocks they take less time in
the kiln and conventional bricks saving
energy and money but they're currently
not quite as strong meanwhile the Tokyo
Metropolitan University graduate school
of system design and developing virtual
body technology that utilizes five
senses visuals are provided by a 3d
monitor headphones for audio it can
create the feeling of wind and spread
smells with a fan a chair that leans
back and forth and vibrates and it even
has foot pedals the idea is to allow
seniors to experience things like
traveling Milan or running the 100-meter
dash like Usain Bolt Gate feeder is a
high-tech way to make sure your proper
cat gets the proper food only the cat
wearing the right RFID tag collar can
open the door preventing other cats who
might bully each other out of the food
interrupting regular meals or special
diets world's largest round Pizza roboy
aims to be the most modern tending
driven robot in the world the artificial
intelligence lab of the University of
Zurich is building this open-source
humanoid service robot in only nine
months and they intend for roboy to be
helpful to humans and hopefully not
destroy us sound bottle was designed by
Jun Fujiwara of Tama Art University to
record the soundtrack of everyday life
it makes a database of sound sources and
forms music with automatic repetitions
[Music]
it turns out belly buttons are like
rainforests of bacteria a recent study
found that from sixty bellybuttons 2368
bacterial species were found one
thousand four hundred and fifty eight of
which may be new to science so yeah
tech jets robot dragonfly is a
palm-sized robot that flies like a bird
hovers like an insect and it's designed
for aerial photography gaming and
security this award-winning Wi-Fi
enabled micro flying insect has 20
environmental sensors GPS capabilities
and HD cameras you can also customize
color and even the wing design find the
link below for more honey you burn in
the ice cubes again and it's just
calcium carbide reacting with water to
form acetylene gas all right finally
fire wall is an interactive media
installation by Erin Sherwood in which a
sheet of spandex acts as an interface to
create fire like visuals and play music
I'm gonna leave you with a robot and
juggles without any sensors and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]